how are you gerald I'm doing Aria how
you doing I'm doing fine how's it been
with cameras following you around oh
it's good man uh you know I ain't got no
problem with a camera being in my face
so you know I feel like if you can't
perform with a camera in front of you -
you know Ross for the last I checked
these tons of cameras around us on game
day so it ain't no different to me well
it's game day is one thing but I mean
found you found you everywhere
everywhere you guys are they there right
now are the cameras there right now Joe
yeah the cameras are here they're not in
this particular element okay all right
here they might be right outside your
door though okay cuz I thought if it was
on right now I'd say hey you know I
don't want anything and come out about
next week's game of Thrones you know run
that up the HBO flag ball right hey hey
listen yesterday their facility came
with rose and ridiculous they will say
that I would agree with you I don't want
to go any further or deeper into it
because what I mean what's your
philosophy on spoiler alerts Gerald I
mean this is just a day after that you
know oh I feel like you know Game of
Thrones it's kind of if you didn't watch
it man that's all you that's not
something you want to miss and movies is
one thing but with it show like Game of
Thrones if you're not making time to try
and watch it or at least see it before
you go to work the next day is all you
you just got to deal with whatever is
gonna be take it was good to miss well
Brockman my guy here on the set flew
back from the Hall of Fame yesterday and
hasn't seen it yet right Chris have not
seen it yet now now I'm a little late
yesterday in Los Angeles hey listen you
need to get you some waffle get you the
HBO app and get it positive well there's
no Saul learning on Airlines Gerald come
on you should know that oh there's no
streaming on airline video on Airlines
yeah no but I mean you have it is you
had some down - yeah you gotta make time
a game before that's true I didn't want
to show up to work groggy on a nice
chair you're professionals right so
itchy
so gerald what's the philosophy for this
team this year I mean it wasn't close to
the playoff appearance last year there
was a six-week stretch when you were a
red-hot team and looking like you'd make
the play
offs what's the expectation level for
this year Gerald yeah well I mean for if
you go from the outside the building you
know the expectation is really high we'd
like you just said we want on the street
people expect us to make the playoffs
last year we just fell short we had some
great pieces like Chris Baker and only
Howard and DeSean Jackson and so on the
soil you know the disguise the limited
people expect us to make the playoffs
for us inside the building the mission
is the same every year getting the
tournament and then go from there
you know but it starts me week one with
going on the road and beating Miami but
for us man is we got to get in the
tournament and then anything goes from
there and speaking of Miami what do you
think about their new quarterback Gerald
McCoy yeah I mean you got everybody has
to make adjustments man and uh Jay
Cutler was out there and they picked him
up and I think he's gonna help him out a
lot man he's a vet so it's different we
got a young guy who's not used to making
changes and having to learn something
really quick and get it going but he's
been the least years man I think he'll
make the transition real quick I think
he's gonna be good for okay are you
saying not just because he's on the weak
one schedule drove McCoy no I'm saying
that because he's a he's a veteran and
uh he got a lot of experience and I
think he feels he may have something to
prove and I think he wants to you know
all the naysayers he wants to prove them
wrong
you know that's why I say that you know
you have two and a half career sacks
against him where you were that Oh sorta
yeah come over where do you remember the
half do you remember the half I'll do
remember to have okay walk me through
the half the half was last year we had a
blitz where I have to stay in the B gap
and I beat one of my former teammates
actually tell Larson in the B gap Robert
Ayers came through on a blitz he rapped
free came and me and Robert hare shared
the sack and then afterwards I did a
mannequin challenge celebration I
remember the mannequin challenge
celebration you did but I don't recall
it being with Cutler involved
although he wasn't he wasn't uh he was
on the ground I don't think he was
involved in the celebration weekend oh
my god Joe McCoy here on the Rich Eisen
show as things are getting started with
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers did you catch
any of the speeches a Hall of Fame
over the weekend I came in at the end of
Jerry Jones and I calls the beginning of
Kurt Warner's what do you think what do
you what do you think when you watch
when you watch get what do you think of
when you watch some of this stuff and
and hear some of these stories Gerald I
want get goosebumps when I don't know
anybody else feel I think
everybody's goal is really yeah you know
I always wanted to vote I think that's
obvious everybody wants win a Super Bowl
but you know I think is the ultimate
honor to put on a gold jacket and I
don't take it for granted I don't play
with that at all you know any form of
simulating a gold jacket or talking
about it or anything like that until you
put that gold jacket on it's just a
fraternity that that you just don't play
with so anytime I see this every year it
gives me goosebumps when I see those
guys receive local jackets I see these
features and this past offseason last
year I had a chance to actually visit
Canton and it was like when I walked
into the room you can just feel the
history and just like how these legends
and you just kind of feel it when you
walk in there man to the point that I
have to just walk out because it started
like my emotions got the best in me man
because it's just Alice's dream to be
able to experience that one day what so
the see these guys do it is like I'm
always so proud of a man and I'm just a
fan everybody who had that opportunity
what's your relationship with Sam Joe
McCoy me and sapper are we pretty tight
man and you know I asked him about his
experience and how he is winning he said
you know his speech was just you know
some guys write him some guys just kind
of tell the story and he said he just
kind of pre missed it because I mean I
don't know Tina
I mean people been around with the guys
he has a great memory so he just kind of
went down you know his life story and
went from there so um you know he talks
to me all the time about being one of
the five only first-ballot Hall of Fame
detectors that is not something that's
easy to do you know and uh just our
relations pretty good couple minutes
left here with Joe McCoy Buccaneers
defensive tackle who is trying to follow
in Sam's footsteps here on the Rich
Eisen show on hitch on some headlines
and get your thoughts on it first up
defensive line coach in Ohio State you
know him his name's Greg Schiano is a
former head coach of yours said the
current D line in the Ohio State most
talented group he's ever coached at any
level including the NFL what did you
think about that oh I think that uh you
know when you when you have it when
you're in a relationship and you're
dating a particular woman when you break
up with her and you get a new girlfriend
I think your current girlfriend at the
time is always supposed to be the best
you ever had
I just think that's how relationships go
you know for a reporter to make a
comment like that when you had Michael
Bennett on your dealer yes this is be
honest Michael Bennett who's done what
he's done a Seattle Adrienne Claiborne
was the first rail pick Daquan bars all
the talent and success he had coming out
of college and going into the league Roy
Miller is going to start nose guard
since he's been in the NFL like to make
a comment like that it's kind of like
this is important right now so this is
who I have to you know I have to pee out
the boast about them I have to make them
seem like the best thing I've ever
experienced it was just how I see it so
that's his opinion and that's his
opinion but for me the guys all around
I'm going to defend them because that's
what those are my brothers that's my
family and that's how I feel about
Jonathan Stewart's opinion is at
Christian McCaffrey his new first round
pick mate on offense is quote/unquote
unstoppable you see him twice this year
what are your thoughts on that Joe well
I mean what you seen in college and
having a guy like that opens
facing one-on-one I don't see that being
I reach you know where his skill set and
how talented he is he's very fast
he's extremely shifty he's strong you
know I don't I don't see that being
reach but only time will tell I won't
say that at all he's reaching right now
or we haven't seen anything only time
will tell as the season goes on we'll
see if that's true but he's been around
them he's seen what he's done in
practice and that's his opinion that's
what he believes you can't knock him for
what he believes in his opinion he need
room for a teammate okay and when I see
Hard Knocks kickoff on a Tuesday at
10:00 East at 10:00 Eastern who's the
guy with the worst language that HBO
needs to bleep out the most who's going
to get that oh oh oh man I don't know I
don't know if guys are censoring
themselves man we got some we got some
language guys and uh Mike Evans is
pretty intense corn Alexander's intense
Robert Ayers Scott Lee that dude you
never know what you go hear from him and
then some of these coaches they get it
going so I would say those three players
and then um old-line coach george
Warhawk man he'd be letting up guys have
it so we'll see I don't know what she
said to themselves where we go see all
right and who breeze the flu breezes
most fire like the dragon Gerald on HBO
who's going to breed more fire dragon or
somebody on the hard knocks on the
Buccaneers all right won't lie we did
Dragon and the dragon one playing oh
sorry buddy
I mean look Carol clearly I don't know
Gerald Georgie no there's no spoiler
spoiler alert there's a dragon in Game
of Thrones and it rains fire okay all
right I'm just saying Gerald right it
ruined it for me I'm coming after you oh
okay sorry sorry all right all right
good chat with you gerald as always
thank you
you got a fairy god bless you made me
good right back at you love chatting
with you and that's the job McCoy at
Geraldine e93 on Twitter here on the
ridge of the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy